all right we turn out to our new  coronavirus numbers out today here at  noon  and across our state nearly a thousand  new cases were reported so our total  now tops 54 000 cases of those 920  people have died  now most of those cases are from clark  county we have nearly 47  000 here 19 new deaths were also  reported yesterday  so 770 people have now died in clark  county  the recovery rate though has gone up to  84 percent so that is some good news  we do update those numbers daily you can  find that on eightnewsnow.com  a new coronavirus test site opens next  week at unlv it is moving over to the  thomas and mack  center the site at the parking garage on  tropicana closed down last week so  everything could be moved over there  testing starts at the thomas and mack  again next week it's tuesdays through  saturdays  from 8 a.m to 4 p.m